make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
hello everyone how's everybody you doing
how you guys doing today you guys having
a good day hope you guys are having a
good day I'm having a great day
so Mighty Avengers yes we are picking up
with Mighty Avengers those of you guys
who are not familiar with Mighty
Avengers we've talked about it we've
never covered it or never covered any of
the stories from because I just want to
cover this one just for the sake of
having it so the way this originally
played out is most of you guys are
familiar with the Civil War event right
superhuman Registration that kind of a
thing Tony Stark was Ford Captain
America was against it he kind of had
two factions of broke out of that right
you had Captain America's Secret
Avengers they were technically called
that best more or less what they were
The Secret Avengers were an actual team
and they were more of less blackops
Avengers team it was kind of cool for a
little while actually and then you had
the the Avengers team assembled by Iron
Man that was designed to be a team of
individuals who were four superhuman
Registration and they were kind of
carrying all that stuff on so initially
this picks up when Thanos shows up on
earth and the Avengers are out in space
fighting against the the builders right
so you got like Thor Captain America all
those guys all facing off against the
against the builders you've got the New
Avengers team which is basically the
Illuminati who are trying to figure out
what was causing the incursions right so
that's what they're doing at the time
and so for the most part you have what
amounts to a skeleton crew of
superheroes on earth and so what you end
up having is you know having the ebony
maw and you have approximate midnight
who were sent to earth along with like
Corvus glaive he sent there as well and
then like supergiant's you know sit
there as well you basically have the
call obsidian of Thanos that's that sent
to earth and while this is going on
while this initial invasion begins to
prep by Thanos you've got Luke Cage
white tiger and Power Man now to kind of
offer a quick little rundown here white
tiger Ava is she's basically like the
fifth person to hold that title honestly
I always thought Casper Cole was the
more interesting character but white
tiger the the concepts been around for a
long long time the reason why she's
wearing a necklace if you look there
she's got like a green amulet that's
what gives her her powers right so she
she doesn't really have powers to speak
up she's an expert martial artist she
has enhanced our ability speed different
things like that so it's your standard
fare she's on par with like Schanke or
iron fists or somebody like that like
she's a capable fighter part of that
that side of Marvel Comics then you have
Victor Alvarez he's the new power man
and his powers actually a little cooler
he was an old school Heroes for Hire
character but he had this visor that he
wore that absorb bio electric energy
there came a point during the events of
our crane which who actually was
technically the Shadowland event with
with daredevil
for those a point where basically bull's
eye blew up the building that him and
his father were in along with like 107
other people or something like that
ended up being that his father and a
hundred seven other people died and with
the fragments of his of his visor
basically Viktor ended up absorbing like
all the bioelectric energy more or less
the Chi of all the people around him and
essentially has the ability to do that
right so he can absorb the Chi of others
and then be able to do all the things
that they can do not like unlimited it's
not like he can absorb the Chi energy
quote-unquote of like Professor Xavier
and then half telepathy does it really
seem to work that way Marvell keeps it
pretty small in scale and they don't
really definitively explain it that it's
kind of leave it contextual so until the
situation comes along where power man
like absorbs the energy of Xavier and
then has telepathy there's no reason to
believe that he can't but the long and
short of it is is with Luke Cage himself
after the events of really like utopia
and all that kind of stuff so
essentially New Avengers vol 2 um kind
of going into issue number 30 in around
2012 he basically ended up leaving the
New Avengers and then going back to
doing Heroes for Hire and the reason why
was because with all the is all the
things that the Avengers do and all the
various escapades they have and the
danger they put themselves in it took
Luke Cage away from his family from
Jessica Jones and Danielle Cage and put
him in jeopardy right not only that but
you know after the events of like Secret
Invasion it also put them in jeopardy
right so it was one of these things of
okay let's go back to kind of live a
normal life so I don't have to worry
about my family dying all the time or me
dying all the time or whatever it is you
know and so he ended up leaving and kind
of going back to more familiar grounds
with Heroes for Hire the important thing
here is that this team is essentially
Heroes for Hire right you got Luke Cage
got white tiger you got Power Man and
they're basically facing off against
this guy the plunderer who ended up
invading or at least showing up on the
docks of horizon labs to essentially
steal a whole bunch of horizon labs tech
which those are the guys who are
familiar with that no this leads to the
introduction or I guess the the showing
up of superior spider-man yes this takes
place during damn slots run and the
superior spider-man story right that's
that's when all this kind of takes place
and so you basically have superior
spider-man who shows up you know and he
and he really tries to deal with it on
his own now the important thing to
understand here is that over the course
of superior spider-man precious few
people knew that superior spider-man was
actually Doctor Octopus who took over
the body of Peter Parker and so as far
as everybody here is aware it's actually
spider-man it's pure he's speaking
uncharacteristically
but it is kind of chalking up to like an
attitude shift or something like that
right Peter Parker just got fed up
basically you know he's just kind of
been a dick for like the last few months
that's more or less what people kind of
kind of see it as right like his
favorite restaurant closed and now he's
pissed but it's one of these funny
things where he almost kind of like
makes fun of them he refers to the
Heroes for Hire is like mercenaries you
know is just like you know guys who were
just like small-time right he calls him
a shoddy gang and in Luke Cage kind of
takes that personally but in reality
that's always kind of what Heroes for
Hire was right I mean Luke Cage
literally flew across the world and went
after dr. doom to collect 200 bucks
right I've got a video on it down in the
description like go check it out it's
it's hilarious like this that's what
made him cool back in the day is there
were a super ground-level team that in
the comedy between Luke agen and iron
fists but they were always kind of
considered to be a sort of ragtag team
right like barely holding it together
running on a shoestring budget that's
how they always sort of work and so it's
one of these cool little references
these cool little Easter eggs if you
know the history of Luke Cage and the
history of Heroes for Hire but
essentially you end up having white
tiger who kind of chimes in here and
says hey look you know I'm gonna follow
spider-man's lead here you know there
has to be something better than this you
know I did this whole thing to honor my
family now the reality is there's
history between those two characters
between spider-man and an Ava up back
during the day or at least back in the
day you had a guy by the name of Gideon
mace and Gideon mace was a character who
ended up basically killing or at least
going after and I think ultimately
killing um the uncle I think it was of
of white tiger essentially the first
white tiger um ended up ended up killing
him I think it was Peter Parker ended up
tracking down Gideon mace and then
basically busted him and then I think
had him turned in and then Gideon maze
ended up dying later on but because of
the fact that Peter was able to get you
know to get some measure of revenge for
her family which Abel was not able to do
at the time she's always kind of had a
respect for right now eventually she
became white tiger and then became a
superhero but her philosophy was always
like we do this for the betterment of
the world and we do it to it to make the
world a better place we don't really do
it for money right like as far as the
Heroes for Hire is concerned their
philosophy is like if the money's there
we don't care that was actually the
tagline for painkiller already the
podcasts back in the day if you guys
don't know I was actually on an episode
of that it was super cool ran at
woodysgamertag and all those guys it was
awesome I'll leave that down in the
description too but as a result of that
we end up basically having white tiger
who essentially comes up with the idea
or really indicates that she's leaving
the team while she's leading Heroes for
Hire which really just kind of leaves
Luke Cage and power
who don't necessarily see eye-to-eye
right and so what we end up doing is
shifting over to a villain by the name
of Blue Streak right and that's kind of
the thing that's going on here and I
hope you guys are kind of noticing this
it's one of these scenarios where with
the x-men kind of doing their thing
being often and really staying isolated
from the world for the most part because
the x-men don't really get involved in
superhero antics unless it involves them
specifically right they're not really
like the world's protectors and with the
Avengers being off planet and being out
in space then like it's a kidney candy
store for all the villains right they're
just out doing their thing right you
know when when the boss is away or in
the cat's away the mouse will play and
that's that's really what this is and so
Blue Streak sucks right he's just he's
on rollerblades which haven't been of
things it's like 1997 but he's on
rollerblades and ultimately he's caught
up to by spectrum Monica Rambeau
now the cool thing about Monica Rambeau
she was Miss Marla four times she really
came into her own when she became
spectrum and she remained that way for
quite some time but even then during the
time this story was written she can
manipulate all different forms of light
energy basically and I like everything
across the electromagnetic spectrum
hence the name but but a Ewing is the
one who's writing this story and so it
makes sense that by the time we got to
Ultimates during the events of all-new
all-different marvel or whatever it was
al Ewing was like bullets expand on her
character right like let's basically
have her character made of like pure
light different things around those it's
Adam Bashir figured a lot of that stuff
out but nonetheless basically she takes
out blue streak pretty quickly and then
like he ends up like I think she busts a
windshield in the process and he and
she's like just blame it on him and then
leaves she's kind of a jerk but we end
up basically having her traveling to to
kind of like where she gets her costumes
done different things like that which is
actually one of the cool things about al
Ewing he's very Chris Claremont in that
regard right like a lot of writers now
just basically focus on like the events
whether it was kind of like okay
the Avengers are here and they're
fighting a bad guy and then they win and
the next story arc is now another bad
guys shown up and they win you don't
really get to see this stuff in between
the stories and that's what made Chris
Claremont writing so good but it's also
one of the cool little tidbits that you
get with with with al ewing when he
writes right he's one of the reasons why
he's one of my favorite writers but then
Monica Rambeau is basically met by a guy
that we're not really given privy to we
can't really see this particular person
you know the reason why this whole thing
happens or why the two of them meet up
is because one they were already meeting
and two this coincides with the arrival
of Proxima midnight along with a whole
bunch of fan OSes out writers and
basically launching an attack against
New York now at the time this is going
on and this was kind of
highlighted in Infiniti and also shown
here dr. strange has essentially been
manipulated by the law now the coolest
thing about ebony MA and the one thing I
did not like about him with infinity war
is ebony Mar was super dangerous because
he could talk you into things right he
had the gift of gab he didn't have like
telepathy or telekinesis or anything
like that he didn't have any powers did
you just talk you into doing things but
the idea is with Proxima midnight
showing up you know her alongside the
outriders the various forces of Thanos
you know they they really just kind of
you know begin attacking explosions are
going on different things like that and
that's when we switch over to Monica and
this this guy she's talking to right
it's his whole response is people aren't
supposed to know that I'm here and so
she's like well let me just put on the
costume right and so he ends up actually
donning this this costume and going by
the name of spider hero now 50 points to
whoever it is I can guess who this guy
is
know using the Marvel wiki you cannot
cheat let me know if you know who this
guy is because I know and if you do know
who he is it's a really cool Easter Egg
right it's a really cool little
appearance here and he'll actually end
up joining the team for a really really
short amount of time which is kind of
cool at the same time because this
attack takes place in New York we also
see superior spider-man joining the
Mighty Avengers as well right so much
like the original New Avengers that came
together because electro took down power
to the supervillain prison the raft this
team came together more or less by
circumstance right so it's kind of a
cool thing because when they all join up
and they all end up fighting Proxima
midnight doesn't really take them
seriously because you know whether we're
the response of a really the question of
Luke Cage is like let's get the Avengers
rightly this lists let's find the
Avengers like somebody get a hold of him
I would eat big guns Thor Hulk all those
guys the response of superior spider-man
is well they're in space they're not
here so I don't know what to tell you
and so Proxima midnight kind of makes
fun of them alone it right like that's
why we're here on earth right now is
because you have nobody protecting it
also the luke cage's response is if you
want the avengers and that's fine were
the Avengers right like we here are now
the Avengers since the formation of the
Mighty Avengers and so what you end up
getting is this really cool battle
between all these guys and again you
kind of had these villains who are more
or less somewhat reformed that we're
working for superior spider-man
he's using him as cannon fodder right
there they know one of the guys is like
you know I really don't want to die he's
like what am I paying you for
if that's the case like go die and if
you die that's just the way it goes but
the funny thing about this is that the
Mighty Avengers are able to put up a
pretty credible threat now the most
powerful of all these guys here is
spectrum by a wide margin why she's
definitely in a mega level threat being
able
manipulate the entirety of the
electromagnetic spectrum is no small
thing she could wipe out all life on
earth as she chose to write she's
clearly in the upper echelon but the
cool thing about this is that by the end
of this story we're going to get another
person added onto this team who's going
to be very oaky it's gonna be really
really cool I put on the less the the
Mighty Avengers are able to hold their
own pretty well and that's kind of a
cool thing right because I mean you've
got that you've got Luke Cage who has
indestructible skin right he can't die
off things like radiation poisoning or
if he dropped him from the top of like
the Empire State Building just by having
like the impact of his organs smashing
against his bones in his body when he
hits the ground
his skin wouldn't break but like his
it'd be like an explosion went off
inside of them and all that kind of
stuff so yeah there's there's ways to
kill him right just because he has
indestructible skin does not mean he
cannot be destroyed but what you also
have here it's part of the Knights spear
and the cool thing about it is that it
basically impacts you know the spear of
Proxima midnight basically operates on a
light level right so it's the perfect
way to essentially take out spectrum
right it's fighting fire with fire and
that's exactly what happened she ends up
falling fast like as soon as she goes
down almost everybody else begins to go
down with it because what you end up
having is Proxima midnight who takes it
to Luke Cage and then is actually able
to break skin and then we have the
introduction of probably one of the most
powerful people ever in the history of
Marvel Comics this old woman right here
because she's just kind of likely she
calls Proxima midnight of fascists and
she's like you cannot pass this old
lady's got some balls she throws a brick
at Proxima midnight so like beyond Omega
level this old lady like the old lady
that's what we're gonna call her but
like the neighborhood's fighting back
and that's one of the cool things that
you don't really get to see a lot when
it comes to these kinds of stories I
mean you're talking about somebody like
Proxima midnight with like enhanced
strength and durability and well able to
withstand like a brick but you don't
really get to see a lot of stories we're
like the neighborhood fights back that's
one of the cool things about the old
Fantastic Four stories you know where
you have like Wyatt Wingfoot and you had
like Yancy Street and you would see like
the neighborhood fight back against a
threat you don't really see that much
anymore
right I mean the Marvel model kind of
operates under this idea that like
people are helpless and can't really do
anything right and like the superheroes
are gonna save the day because what's
Humanity gonna do this old lady and
here's a crazy thing this old lady is
about to be like taken out right like
she's about to get destroyed by Proxima
midnight we'll just kind of messed up
right like attacking grandma butt plug
it's that's just something you don't do
Luke Cage of course ends up catching
your hand in time and basically starts
taking its approximate midnight and
that's what
you kind of see the team begin to sort
of rebound right kind of begin to come
back but in the middle of it all
suddenly this voice comes out and says
stop right thatís basically chimes in
and says you promised me a dead City now
again danos he's the big guy run in the
show here he brought together the coal
obsidian they would all fall before him
right like the annals would just did
just destroy every single one of them
Proxima midnight being instructed by
Thanos it's like you told me he would
conquer this city you know you need to
go like I sent you here to go take care
of Namor
you said you could take care of New York
obviously you can't uh so go take care
of the task that I assigned you and like
we'll just leave this place or we won't
worry about it now the reality is vanos
knows what's going on right neva Proxima
midnight does so her whole response here
is I told you guys I was going to make
this quick I told you guys that I would
I would kill you fast but you guys
wanted to fight and you guys wanted to
battle so now you've got to deal with
what the MA has planned for you and
that's gonna be very very painful and
very very slow and the reason why is
because as that happens suddenly you
have this disembodied voice chiming in
out of nowhere saying before all was I
was before time was I waited right I fed
on on the screaming souls of universes I
drank the spoiled milk of dead stars
I am the emptiness outside all
understanding I am Shuma gorath this guy
is would easily be able to destroy the
entirety of the Avengers team no this is
kind of a quoting me you don't really
get to see all that often in Marvel
right well we don't really get to see
Shu McGrath all that often but to like
seeing this happen is cool because it
means fan oohs knows who Shu McGrath is
right Thanos and his forces are aware of
who this guy is and that's something
that you never really get to see
reference right we've never seen vanos
reference Shu McGrath ever in the
history of Marvel and it's awesome to
see him here right now in terms of what
happened next it's the coolest thing
ever the reason why is because we end up
switching over for a forgotten hero who
was once a global protector we pick up
with none other than Adam Brashear and
Adam Brashear has been met with the
arrival of who watching The Watcher you
know and and it's kind of like why are
you here right because they've hung out
before they know who the other is the
watcher has a very particular interest
in Adam Bashir because of how powerful
Adam Bashir is and and Adams like why
are you here right like I guess
something's about to pop off the world's
about to end or something like that and
The Watcher doesn't really say anything
he's like okay fine like I guess that's
the case like you know like
whatever like you know I ended up moving
out of the house after my after my wife
died and you know it's just it was too
painful to be there but like if what
your tale if you're here that means
things are about to pop off and the
Watchers not saying anything because of
his whole pact of non-intervention
but Adam kind of tries to blow it off
like I really don't want to have to act
I really don't want to have to get
involved I just want to stay here I just
want to focus on my things when I get
involved people get hurt I just want to
stay here I don't want to have any Oh
have any involvement where the watcher
just keeps staying and the watcher just
keeps staring and so Adam says okay fine
so he goes to his device which is
designed to monitor earth for various
threats and he's met with the arrival of
a level seven invasion and it's like
what in the heck is a level seven threat
right he's like he's like I've had that
I built this thing and I've never seen
anything more than a level four right so
level seven seems to be the most extreme
indication the result of this is that
Adam Brashear dons a suit and Adam
Bashir goes flying into action for no
other purpose than to face off against
Shu McGrath yes ladies and gentlemen in
the next video that we will cover it
will be the blue Marvel versus Shuma
gorath way that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoy these
cliffhangers
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]